in Hollywood actors and writers usually
have to grind away for years sometimes
even decades before that break comes
along a big part of that struggle is
pursuing the perfection of the craft
honing their skills to the point where
their talents can't be ignored it can be
an all-consuming process and leave
little time for pursuing any other
dreams this makes it all the more
impressive when a Hollywood star known
primarily for acting sneaks behind the
keyboard and works on a script here are
some of the Hollywood stars who secretly
helped write your favorite movies Carrie
Fisher as far as career defining roles
go you could do a lot worse than
Princess Leia one of the great on-screen
heroines of all time fortunately for us
the late great Carrie Fisher wasn't keen
to settle for just being iconic
on-screen
according to slash film she also made a
living as a screenwriter and as one of
the most in-demand script doctors in
Hollywood Fisher was the primary screen
writer for the semi-autobiographical
film postcards from the edge as well as
these old broads and she helped fix a
variety of scripts over the course of
her career her fingerprints are on
everything from hook to sister act to
mr. and mrs. Smith she's also on record
as saying she rewrote some of her
dialogue as layer on with son of the
Jedi and even helped out with the script
for what ended up being a final film
Star Wars Episode eights the last Jedi
Joel Edgerton over the last several
years joel edgerton has proven himself a
reliable actor performing very well in
films like warrior and 0.30 his
filmography is peppered with a writing
credits here and there but in 2015 he
made his proper debut with a riveting
thriller called the gift which he wrote
directed and starred in the script draws
heavily from the structure and pacing
pioneered by acclaimed directors like
Alfred Hitchcock and Brian De Palma and
critics praised both his performance and
the work he did off screen as well
Edgerton will be back as a writer and
director with the film boy erased and
this looking like another Korea
highlights Wentworth Miller in 2005
Wentworth Miller hit TV screens
everywhere on the TV show Prison Break
he proved to be a charismatic intense
performer and later went on to bring
life to comic book supervillain Captain
cold on the CW's of Flash and legends of
tomorrow despite how talented he is on
screen his work is considerably
mainstream his writing
Miller made his screenwriting debut with
Stoker a tense erotic thriller that
takes a sadistic glee in winding its
characters for a downward spiral the
screenplay is incredibly effective but
unfortunately his follow up the
disappointments room wasn't
well-received at all he is hoping Stoker
wasn't a fluke just in thorough with
movie star looks and an easygoing
charisma Justin Theroux is the kind of
actor who could easily coast by with the
Curia in mainstream action movies and
romantic comedies but his career has
been anything but conventional Thoreau
is well known for his appearances in
films like Mahalo and drive and for his
leading role in the HBO series the
leftovers the only thing more surprising
than Thoreau's choices an actor is a
path he's taken as an accomplished
writer his two most notable scripts are
2008 acclaimed comedy Tropic Thunder and
Marvel's Ironman tear and he also worked
on Rock of Ages and Zoolander 2 the row
tends to apply as acting talents to more
artistic fare while utilizing his knack
for blog posts of storytelling as a
screenwriter which seems like a pretty
cool career choice Paul Rudd it's tough
to point to a leading man in modern
comedy more reliable than Paul Rudd from
the 40 year old virgin to ant-man his
easygoing charm and sense of humor have
made for a great career in the genre it
only makes sense that he'd have a knack
for it behind the keyboard as well Rudd
has writing credits on two of his films
the first as role models 2008 comedy
directed by rods longtime friend and
collaborator David Wain the second
featured his biggest role yet in 2015's
ant-man according to Deadline after the
film was handed off from a touch
director Edgar Wright but did a rewrite
of the script with anchorman writer and
director Adam McKay it seems like Rudd
may be most memorable on-screen when
he's written the parts he's playing Jim
rash in addition to guest starring on a
wide array of TV comedies Jim rash was
also a series regular on the acclaimed
cult classic community but credits like
that you may be surprised to find that
Russia's big-screen debut as a writer it
significantly more serious than his work
as an actor fresh collaborated with
director Alexander Payne on 2011's The
Descendants an acclaimed oscar-nominated
family drama for which Rush won the
Oscar for Best Adapted Screenplay his
follow-up was a coming-of-age drama d
the way way back which
as Matt were similarly wide acclaim
[Music]